Hi, and welcome to Veritasium, an online science video blog.
I'd like to take on scientific topics all the way from the simplest to the most complex.
So a good place to start, I think, is with a problem considered by a famous physicist
Richard Feynman.
He asked if all the world's scientific information, except for one sentence, were destroyed in
some cataclysmic event, which single statement would contain the most scientific information
for future generations.
His conclusion was that it is the atomic hypothesis.
The atomic hypothesis states that all things are made up of atoms.
Tiny particles that are in perpetual motion, they attract each other when a little distance
apart, but repel if squeezed together.
That statement is incredibly important to understand if you want to understand most of
the rest of science, because everything is made of atoms, including you and me, and
the opera house, and the harbor bridge, and the water, and the trees, and the grass,
and the air, and the clouds, and, well, you get the idea.
Everything is made out of atoms, so it's really important to understand the atomic concept
if you're going to understand the rest of science.
The idea that...